[Music]
Hey
okay I read a story that was kind of
redonkulous because there was this a
school called police after a
kindergartener a sick with the school's
name is police Elementary called police
I heard that too I heard it but I knew
that was him I know me too
interrupts the way he did but I'm glad
by the sounds that we discovered in
school with a really cool name
carry on tip I apologize for my nono you
think down because there's a band called
police it's true they got robbed they
call the police but the bad news akan
police police they call it the band
called police
crazy it's so crazy it's cool called the
police
you're fine after a kindergartener with
Down syndrome pointed a finger gun at a
teacher that [ __ ] was
threatening the teacher what's wrong
with the little girl listen that girl
should not threaten death
okay you know there's been a problem of
school shooting yet these days or the
future
she needs to check herself before she
wrecks the school oh I haven't heard
death well what kind of fever gun was it
was it a semiautomatic rocket launcher
oh how illegal were the finger guns you
don't know can cuz it was just a little
revolver then I think they already shot
yeah but if she did the whole like
semi-automatic assault rifle yeah and
what she concealed carry did she like
pulled it out okay well she had bullets
strapped like this she purchased sugar
like this and then [ __ ] put it in wow
that's very imaginative
so she plays cops and robbers with
her brother all the time and so that's
the reason why when she was at school
she was just like ah but the school
clearly took it too far by calling the
cops
yeah don't step on a crowd yeah you
break your mom's back don't step on a
crack all right we'll find a hole fine
it won't don't worry okay sorry but yeah
are you gonna do this without me find it
we'll fight we'll find it okay so this
is Margo and her mama and the mom was
very upset yeah at the school board
because she was like it literally does
not say in the policy that you must call
the cop like it was just ridiculous and
if it's pop teacher turf yes who were
was this uh this was in Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania make a lot of
pencils that's where the Amish people
are true yeah hey my uncle lived there
and he died of AIDS you talked about
this yeah rest in peace thank you was he
Amish
no oh yeah the mother was saying that
the district misinterpreted its own
policy so she said it was very clear
from the beginning that she didn't
understand what she was saying her heavy
bowel syndrome is one aspect of it but
I'm sure most six-year-olds don't
understand what that means
oh [ __ ] Oh
bite your ear I've gotta keep it on your
policeman is the force to lava though
yeah he did it playing the game like
Peter on but thinking about you
we're chill we're all Chuck I mean my
feet are getting really hot but they're
not touching the lava I think you might
be okay now I don't think so I don't
I'll watch you do
okay you're right yeah tell me first
yeah anyway something district was
saying that the police didn't end up
investigating and they were just that
they agreed to review the safety
practices after these concerns were
brought up at the school board policy
meeting I think the teacher needs to get
reviewed for safety policies because she
could not save any of those kids or help
them I had a home in high school that um
he got kicked out of school he got he
got suspended for a couple days cuz he
brought a gun a toy gun to school right
and when he told me the story he was
like he's an AA guy kicked out I brought
a gun to school right and then his his
home his home he was like boy it was a
keychain it was a small gun it was a
small good but then my boy was like no I
was a Glock it was a glass haha I like I
like a rope to the volcano in there in
the forward hold it was lava man yeah
that's what he did friend brought a
Rambo knife but the plastic one for
show-and-tell this is from Rambo and he
pulled it out so it's all [ __ ] and
the teacher was like Joe has on teeth
marks no oh but crazy [ __ ] about about
plastic knives though cuz one time in
second grade mrs. condo she took one of
the one somebody's Power Ranger gun I'll
pound her knife the the Green Ranger he
had like a blade right didn't he and um
so mrs. Connor was like I know you guys
might think oh this is just plastic it's
not a big deal but she's like watch this
she took an apple a red apple and she
took a plastic straw like this
she's like watch this she went and put
that straw through the yeah yeah it was
like hose we didn't say [ __ ] were like
oh snap and then she started drinking
the apple juice she smoked it in front
of us turn into a bomb
smoking it was a kid I'm like oh sick
now I can stab my buddy with a [ __ ]
drink his blood but yeah it was like we
were all like oh okay we get your point
mrs. condo that's pretty crazy I think
it's second grade I put a brown play-doh
it says it all back for sure it does it
is my dog's poop and I got set the time
out and all that no it's not poop it's
just brown play-doh but the teacher
already already over it
teachers not gonna check she's like I
don't care that will be fine if you
brought a bag of [ __ ] this look like
real poop I just made the wrinkles the
residue in the bag it doesn't count it
doesn't know you're all smelling it
you're eating it yeah the teacher never
sense of humor the midnight pulled it on
I think she's always so tired of my [ __ ]
she's like go over there but she was
like I'm more than a heavy [ __ ] you
should have eaten it she's taking a bite
test I could done anything while these
days no one speed is on the girl she's
me did you guys become shy cuz I was
just thinking about show-and-tell right
that she was one of my favorite
[ __ ] things on the world I was
like I can't wait I would look for
things to like oh they gotta guess what
this [ __ ] show until once in my
elementary career I did like I think I
was shy once I hit puberty really yeah
like degrees were you weren't shy growth
spurt that's why your mustache started
growing out maybe I shouldn't show this
to the world
well I think it was cuz I started liking
boys more so I was like oh I liked them
and then you know they didn't like me
back I started liking boys before
puberty hit that's when I started
getting shy once I started liking boys
man I like girls because you're afraid
of me I'm not liking you or being
nervous or oh you know it was a
combination of things so it was the fact
that I wanted to be liked by the boys
that I liked and it was also the girls
in that like great I forgot what great
it was but when you're younger like
girls into being really judgmental of
other girls so then that kind of taught
me like don't they stay that way every
great honestly yes so yeah and then
that's when I started getting more
self-conscious cuz I'm like oh my god I
want to be judged the way they're
judging everyone else and that's when I
started getting shy I've never heard
like a bunch of boys at least from just
my personal experience judging and
saying [ __ ] to girls the way that girls
do it's so [ __ ] mean I had some guys
come on remember the ear thing came from
a boy like the reason why I got he
probably liked you know it was it was a
drive-by insults I mean he was right how
much it stood out my reception fool
hey big ears look he was running past me
he goes haha
you have big ears and honey yeah I was
like in the sixth grade and then
obviously cuz I still I used to have my
hair like this - so it just made it
worse but like I used to have like a
really low ponytail so it's like stuck
out I guess more and yeah since the 6th
grade up until meeting you guys I had
like an ear insecure oh that's crazy
because your ears are only 30% of your
head like and that's not that bad don't
use a [ __ ] math in here no like I'd
say 3544 yeah it was the boys that made
me insecure about my kids too like you
know like I remember there was this one
kid Damien he would always
but not just to me like every girl was
like haha I could iron my shirt or your
chest Oh where's Mei Lee the boy that
brought up a lot of this stuff what the
things that I heard a girl on your back
like yeah you could I need [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] that I heard from the
girls wouldn't their friend left don't
talk [ __ ] I was like hey I know guys
that do that [ __ ] well that's what I'm
saying it's from my own experience I've
never seen that and I was like wow like
at such a young age like my mind isn't
even on that level
of like hey we're friend of meze man do
you know it's just weird it's like I'm
like what the [ __ ] it's like that's not
what I'm even thinking about I never met
a guy who even gave a [ __ ]
they're like oh my god I can't wait to
[ __ ] a chick like oh no her chest is too
flat for me I never met a guy like that
I heard they were too insecure to even
go for the girls so they had to
immediately like reject oh yeah yeah hey
why they want interested in other I knew
guys that were the opposite don't like
damn you see those titties and I'm like
huh you like and they look at me like
you gay but I'm all like I have a
preference he goes
she got big titties man wait no and I'm
like to tag girls Oh peace not my style
just not for me
look what what we need to remember is
that Steve's uncle died of AIDS
the floor is too lava could reach mine I
can maybe get this one what the board
table breathe
[Music]
you